this idea of social practice is one that
a lot of theorists and critics have have
have talked about and tried to frame I
think of social practice as an
engagement in art making within a more
recent contemporary moment although
there are historical antecedents perhaps
many decades prior to - now we might
think in relatively speaking last 30 to
50 years some of these pieces start to
come together but one person who I've
looked at to help theorize this notion
of social practices educator and artist
Pablo Higuera Higuera says unlike social
work that aims for dignity and
strengthening human relationships a
socially engaged artist may subscribe to
those same values but make work that
Iren eise's problematizes and even
enhances the tensions around those
subjects in order to provoke reflection
so that in part of the phrase to provoke
reflection that I bring into the
classroom or that I try to Center some
of my work or my work around this idea
of what might we do to provoke
reflection not only in other people but
also in myself perhaps the work becomes
a provocation in that sense and why
would we want to do that well how Guerra
says we want to do that perhaps to
discover something in the process you
know these artists he considers them me
renamed some free agents if you will
they insert themselves into the most
unexpected social environments and they
do so in ways that break away from
disciplinary boundaries hoping to
discover something new in the process so
the idea of inserting oneself into an
unexpected place or to perform a certain
engaged verse and a certain behavior or
a certain interaction when it's not
expected we would do that hoping to
discover something in the process so
these two terms socially engaged art and
social practice are connected how Guerra
prefers socially engaged art because it
still has that word art and he shortens
it to bsea but society of social
practice is a wider range in corpus is a
is a term that seems to be a bit
or wide or wide and more widely
encompassing of the range of practices
that might might fit those definitions
so to go on just a couple of more bits
from Hell Guerra and there are other
folks like Clare Bishop and grant caster
and other folks who theorize and talk
about socially engaged art but I find
how Clara has approached quite useful so
he talks about socially engaged art or
social practice as a multi-layered and a
participatory engagement and he says
that there are these structures multiple
structures are multiple layers among
which are nominal participation directed
participation creative participation and
collaborative so there might be multiple
ways to participate or engage or the
public or other individuals within this
practice how Guerra also talks about the
idea of how these practices are linked
to other disciplines specifically we
find tension between art practice and
sociology or social practice but that
trying to make sense of those tensions
and say it's more art it's like 85% this
and we're 16% of this it's something
that's not what he's talking about he
says we want to stay in that unresolved
space it's it's it it comes at us
perhaps through an art a sense of art
practices and disciplinary
considerations but that we want it to
remain in that unresolved space we want
it to be a bit messy so here's a bit of
a longer one and then we'll move beyond
some of the theorizing how gross a
social interaction occupies a central
and inextricable part of any socially
engaged art work you got to have the
social interaction just doing something
and then hang it up and not seeing and
not having other people become
participants at one of those layers is
not is not enough although one might
argue that any artwork is a socially
engaged practice once you put let's say
a painting or a sculpture out to be seen
at least one person seeing and it's
already engaged in the social
relationship but he how girl goes
further he says socially engaged art is
a hybrid multidisciplinary activity that
exists somewhere between art and non-art
and what has to happen is you have to
have
actual and not hypothetical not imagined
social action you actually have to
engage with other people so last week
outside in front of the building we
created ceramic water filters we mixed
clay and sawdust and we had several
people stop by to see what we were up to
get their hands dirty we brought that
mixture of clay and sawdust back
upstairs and we made ceramic water
filters and these water filters will
render contaminated water with microbes
and pathogens it will render it potable
and so this practice of performing these
the construction and and that the the
production of ceramic water filters fits
within el Guerra's notion of socially
engaged art so I'm telling you that as
kind of a back step to what we did last
week but also to give you a specific
example but then I want to give you some
other examples and some of the examples
that I want to share with you push this
idea of telling stories that might not
be told otherwise I was in a course I
was teaching a course a few years ago to
undergraduate art education students
we're trying to make sense of what is it
that art does why are we teaching art
what is what is what's the central
importance or what seems to be at the
core not that there might be a singular
core but there could be multiple cores
and one of the students said you know
what I think art allows us to tell
stories that we would not be able to
tell otherwise and in some ways we might
not be able to tell them where we
probably shouldn't tell them otherwise
as completely through art practice and
so I I kind of latch onto that but I'd
like to add the difficult stories the
work that I try to do is interested in
that those difficult stories that might
not be told otherwise not that they're
not told but they wouldn't be told in
the same ways that socially engaged art
would do that so as I think about this
approach to telling difficult stories I
think of the word double take when you
see something and then you have to look
again this is a double take right you
you see it once but it caused you to
stop and and take a second look we might
think of research in the same way we can
search but when we research we search
again it's to look again to do this
double take I also appreciate the idea
of making trouble not only the idea of
troubling something through the making
of objects or the making of experiences
or making of social actions but the
making of trouble in the idea of
troubling things that others have made
whether they be objects or social
constructs or ideologies so it's this
idea of troublemaking and making trouble
that I'd like to play with in this still
images from when the Marx Brothers films
where Harpo and Groucho essentially the
the mirror breaks and they're they're
mirroring each other so there there's
all this double-take going on there
they're looking and looking again and so
you have this idea of visuality
happening the perspective of the viewer
and but it's through this social
interaction and there are a number of
iterations of that Marx Brothers mirror
scene that play out in cartoons that
play out in other other stories so
otherwise I've made trouble in the past
was and and to think about what we're
seeing and how we're seeing it was to
take a look at February quite often I
have been invited to give talks at
schools or at other institutions and
they'd like to bring man in February I
guess it's because February is about
that month with Valentine's Day and they
know that I'm a very passionate person
but if they look more closely at my work
they say I deal with some difficult
issues and not the least of which is the
construct of racism and that's also the
month where you have Black History Month
and so I'm pretty sure that's why they
bring me in so if we look at February a
bit differently if we engage with that
month not only is it the month where we
let's look at a specific group of others
which suggest there's another construct
against which
we are situating african-americans but
also the idea of February being the
month for Valentine's Day it's the
shortest month of the year and the
shortest month of the year is the year
we said go tell other people how much
you love them I mean you would think a
month with 31 days would be a better
choice for that or maybe all year long
we should think in more passion
inconsiderate ways so this is a work I
did a number of years ago that revolved
around those two concepts I also am
interested in this idea of disruption I
mentioned this briefly last week and I
think disruption happens in a number of
ways pushing back questioning I'm
interested in questioning answers rather
than answering questions one of the ways
I've done that is I've looked at barber
shops as pedagogical spaces as
curriculum spaces what can we learn in a
barber shop and I wrote an article about
Pat's barber shop in Norfolk Virginia
and I tried to make the case that what
happens in a barber shop is a is a
hypertextual multi-layered multifaceted
learner-centered space of inquiry that
you might go in trying to get a haircut
but you'll come out with an education
and this happens in all sorts of service
locations you know hair salons and other
places where conversation becomes
essential to those locations but also
written about digital technology when my
wife and I learned we were expecting our
the birth of our daughter I started to
think well that's fantastic and I
thought oh my goodness I'm going to be
someone's parent and oh I need to think
this through now this is this is a big
deal so I started writing myself a
series of emails to explain to our
unborn child who I thought I was and
what I was working through and so that
series of emails became an article that
I were chapter it's a common email from
a digital daddy and I was trying to make
make sense of how that her future
existence and identity would be mediated
through digital technology but what came
through in that in the process of that
was her multi-ethnic identity and the
ways that I am at
camera technology surveillance
technology being scrutinized at airports
among other approaches would render her
body the object of examination
shift not a tell you story about Henry
Brown I'm not sure if you're familiar
with the Henry Braun who I think about
quite often Henry Brown lived in
Virginia outside of Richmond in Henrico
County and there's Henry in the middle
he's inside this box and there's some
people outside the box so I guess
they're thinking outside the box and the
story of Henry Brown was told by himself
he narrated this this in their story of
himself and there are many versions or
at least you know it was published in a
number of different contexts another
number of different formats and so Henry
Brown earned the name Henry box Brown
and he was in that box for a reason I'm
gonna let you know why in just a second
I brought I didn't bring them in we have
obtained a couple of pallets and I put
the wooden pallets on the the floor here
so you have these two wooden pallets on
the floor and I want to read you a story
it's not a story that I wrote Henry
wrote it but it's been retold and it is
retold by Ellen Levine and the story is
Henry's freedombox a true story from the
Underground Railroad the reason that I'm
reading this to you on these pallets
what you see are two pallets and this
book that I put on a sidewalk in the
middle of campus last year and I let it
sit there for 10 minutes or so and then
I sat on the pallets and I'm going and I
read this story the way I'm going to
read it to you and people walk by some
of them stopped and listened and others
did not
Henry's freedombox Henry Brown wasn't
sure how old he was
Henry was a slave and slaves weren't
allowed to know their birthdays Henry
and his brothers and sisters worked in
the big house where the master lived
henry's master had been good to Henry
and his family but Henry's mother knew
things could change do you see those Lee
he's blowing in the wind there from the
trees like the slave children are torn
from their families one morning the
master called for Henry and his mother
they climbed the wide staircase the
master lay in the bed with only his head
above the quilt he was very ill he
beckoned them to come closer some slaves
were freed by their owners Henry's heart
beat fast maybe the master would set him
free but the master said you're a good
worker Henry I'm giving you to my son
you must obey Him and never tell a lie I
will mail myself to a place where there
are no slaves he said Henry are you all
right in there all right he answered the
cover was pried open
Henry stretched and stood up four men
smiled at him welcome to Philadelphia at
last Henry had a birthday March 30 18-49
his first day of freedom and from that
day on he also had a middle name
everyone called him Henry box Brown so
this is the story of Henry box Brown is
told in a in a children's book by Evelyn
Levine and it was illustrated by Kadir
Nelson why did I read that story to you
well I wanted you to hear the story of
Henry box Brown not the way that he told
it by the way that it was retold for
children that's a children's book it's
meant to be a children's book it's meant
for children to hear that story and it's
a story that I've read as a bedtime
story to our daughter there are
different versions of Henry's freedombox
different store until Drance versions
and different adult versions of telling
those story there are art approaches too
there's a monument to Henry Brown in
Richmond Virginia and this is a
sculpture made out of metal the same
dimensions as that box that Henry was in
an etched in the ground it says in a
wooden crate similar to this one Henry
Brown a Richmond tobacco worker made the
journey from slavery to freedom in 18-49
and that box is interesting because the
the lid is off as you saw in the
previous image
but one side is open and it's open with
a silhouette of a man crouched down now
Henry Brown was five eight I'm five
eight and I was compelled to get inside
that box and this idea of for Henry
thinking outside of the box meant
literally to think inside the box and to
put himself into a situation that was
disrupting the current practices but he
was at at a point at which he was
willing to try anything now this story
with Henry Brown can be retold and can
be recreating be reproduced and and
there are some folks who I you know I
make these connections the image on the
left is actually someone who is trying
to get themselves out of a particular
situation putting themselves inside a
suitcase and mailing oneself out of a
horrible situation the image on the
right is actually a white student in
blackface as a Halloween costume going
as Henry box Brown now both of these
images relate directly to the Henry box
Brown story for me but in different ways
they can be unpacked no pun intended to
deal with various levels of a class of
identity of social situation of systems
of oppression and expectations this idea
of reading in public places just like I
did with the Henry Brown work last year
and also here I think is an important
piece to consider and the way in which
we read to children I think is important
words are very important words are
powerful there are games that we play
through social media in public spaces
like words with friends I play this game
quite often but there are some words
that are unacceptable I think what
there's some words that aren't well if
you misspelled it that's probably
unacceptable Negro is an unacceptable
term in words with friends really
because that's the term I think people
need to deal with and address and unpack
Asian is also an unacceptable term in
words with friends now I find these two
examples interesting for the kind of
work that I'm doing but there are some
other words
words that are acceptable and really big
words matter and just like socially
engaged art that moves away from the
materiality and more to the conceptual
and experiential moving from specific
labels to larger concepts and constructs
seems to be more value to words with
friends as well
for example conceptualizing can earn you
one thousand four hundred and sixty nine
points that's a lot of points so maybe
there's something in conceptualizing
that we need to do so how do we
conceptualize telling difficult stories
another children's book good night moon
you might be familiar with this good
night mmm good night cow jumping over
the moon there's this interesting
repetition well Larry Wilmore created a
version of good night moon he called a
good night slavery Larry Wilmore was a
talk show well spin off from the Jon
Stewart Show and so this show with Larry
Wilmore he decided that one of the the
skits that he did was to create a
children's book called good night
slavery inspired by the Texas
Legislature and the Texas Education
Board changing the curriculum and
changing certain terms moving the term
the transatlantic slave trade and
renaming it the transatlantic triangular
trade and so he has this entire piece
where he pulls apart that movement yeah
essentially whitewashing history and so
what you see there are lines from the
book in a big red state there was a text
book in a debate and too many knaves and
one big cave in a book that is shut in a
past full of smut and a cranky
conservative with a stick up his butt
good night slavery good night bravery
good night two things we find unsavory
well what are some of the things that
they might find unsavory well I'll get
to that in a second but this book good
night moon has been told in different
ways it's a it's a
texture within child children's book
culture that gets repurposed and
reimagined some of the ways that Wilmore
understands what is being erased g'night
KKK good night to the decimation of
indigenous people on this continent so
these are all the things that the Texas
curriculum was erasing or modifying or
eliminating or renaming to make them
seem less unsavory and in one more skit
he reads this book to a classroom of
kindergarten children and the reactions
are wonderful but it's also you can tell
it's kind of coached for the for the
skid reading public places different
than reading in public places we could
also read public places for example in
the summer for the past three summers
that opportunity to teach at Vermont
College of Fine Arts and one of the
courses that I teach looks at
participatory inquiry in the public
sphere one of the assignments is for us
to go to the State House the State
Capitol which is just a mile and a half
two miles away from campus and it's the
smallest state capitol in the country
it's very accessible we sign up for a
guided tour and before the tour I give
each student a little figuring that I
bought at the toy store these little
busts of US presidents and I asked the
students to go on the tour to be polite
on the tour but I would like you to read
the State Capitol in conversation with
the tiny president so on our walk down
on our mile and have to walk down
they're on their phones and they're
googling Theodore Roosevelt or Thomas
Jefferson or Abraham Lincoln and then
they take cell phone shots there's a
close up of tiny George and in the back
is big George or please keep off and
they put one of the pres I think that's
Buchanan inside the
Kanon or they end up reading other
people and it's with this tiny president
this tiny object that they're able to
construct stories that couldn't be told
otherwise putting that situation that
context history and and related
information that they have either
brought to that space or that they learn
on the tour in conversation with what
they know about that president
you